>>Female Presenter: Good afternoon everyone,
authors at Google New York is please today
to welcome Howard Friedman.
Howard Friedman is a statistician, health
economist, writer and artist currently employed
at the United Nations Population Fund and
as an adjunct associate professor at Columbia
University.
He is here with us today to discuss his latest
book, "The Measure of a Nation: How to Regain
America's Competitive Edge and Boost Our Global
Standing".
He has a Masters in Statistics and a PhD in
Biomedical Engineering from Johns Hopkins
University.
Please welcome Howard Friedman.
[applause]
>>Howard Friedman: Well, thank you very much
for coming and thank you Google for hosting
today.
I appreciate the opportunity to talk with
everybody.
The book itself is based on this premise of
competitive intelligence and I think people
at Google are well aware of the idea of competitive
intelligence.
Using data to compare yourself to other, in
your case, companies.
I'm sure there's a lot analysis that goes
on here looking at other competitors in the
search space or advertising or in the social
media space.
So it's a very common business practice.
What's not so common is for the United States
to use the same principles to compare themselves
to other countries, see how they're doing
and then use that data to identify opportunities
for improvement as well as to identify areas
where they're excelling and they can leverage
their advantages.
So, the premise behind the book is taking
that basic concept that's used regularly in
the business world and applying it to the
political space.
Seems straight forward, of course there's
going to be some challenges.
At the end of my talk, I'm gonna explain what
are some of the key challenges, but before
we even get to that it's worth putting one
thing on the table right away, which is the
whole idea of American exceptionalism.
The first objection that a lot of people had
to the idea of using competitive intelligence
for the United States, is simply the idea
that America can't be compared to any country.
That we're exceptional, so different that
there's nothing to be learned from the rest
of the world.
Now, obviously that's a very problematic attitude.
It's an attitude that rests in the idea of
blissful ignorance, it prevents you from learning
and it doesn't just seem arrogant, it is arrogant.
So, this whole idea of American exceptionalism
and removing ourselves from the ability to
compare to other counties, we're just going
to have to take that and put it away, because
that defeats the whole opportunity for learning.
With that said, we then want to ask ourselves
the question of competitive intelligence,
who are we competing against?
And that's when we do have to recognize that
the United States is different from other
wealthy countries, in some respects.
There is no other wealthy country that has
the size population of the United States.
If you look at other countries that have large
populations, they're not as wealthy.
And other wealthy countries aren't as populace.
We have to accept that as just the reality
of the number of data points that exist for
countries.
None the less what we did for the book is
identify wealthy countries, that is those
who had a GDP per capita of over twenty thousand,
and large in the sense of having a population
of over 10 million.
The ten million threshold selects the 1/3
largest countries by population and it also
requires that country to have a population
larger than New York City, our largest city.
It's not perfect, but it’s a good enough
criteria to allow us to do the rest of the
conversation, to examine these other countries.
So we have that identified, and after we pass
through those two filters what we find is
there are fourteen countries remaining that
have data.
The fourteen countries generally are populated
in Western Europe.
Additionally there's Canada, The United States,
South Korea, Japan and Australia.
Intuitively these are the countries that you
would expect to compare to the United States
because they have similar levels of socio-economic
quality, they have similar abilities for infrastructure.
So we have our competition, but then what
are we comparing with?
What are the factors we're looking at?
In the book I focused on a few areas; health,
education, safety, democracy and equality.
Those five areas, why those five?
Well first they are fundamental to having
a successful society.
They're critical, they overlap with a lot
of the key areas in social science that have
been built on the idea of societies.
From Maslow's Hierarchy of Needs to Amartya
Sen's models.
More importantly, from my perspective, and
I think everyone here at Google could appreciate
it, there's data.
And it's generally very rich data so we can
analyze it and drawn conclusions versus picking
subjects where it's not quantified.
So we have those five subjects, in today's
discussion I'm going to focus on three of
them.
I'm not going to spend too much time on health.
I think people have heard so much about it
between the Patient Protection and Affordable
Care Act discussion and some of the key facts
that have been already discussed very much
in the media.
And safety's been so much out and about, especially
the last few weeks with the unfortunate shooting.
So I'm going to mention a few quick facts
about that and then I'm going to move to the
other three topics, which I think are going
to be very interesting and we'll see how they're
all interconnected.
The whole basis of the book uses three principles
which are fairly straight forward.
The first one is, if you compare the United
States to other wealthy countries, we're quite
different.
Now that's an obvious statement, one that
anyone who's traveled outside the United States
has probably come to appreciate.
But many Americans don't travel outside the
United States and so they don't recognize
how different we are.
From a quantifiable point of view, it's not
just that we're different, but the second
point is, we're not always the best.
And then the third point, which is pretty
logical from the first two, is and when we're
not always the best, let's see what we can
learn from other countries.
So three basic principles, with that in mind,
I'm going to introduce just a couple quick
facts for you in health and safety and then
I'm going to focus on the other topics.
So in health the key fact that I would want
people to walk away from is just the idea
that the United States spends two to sometimes
five times more on health than other wealthy
countries and we have the lowest life expectancy.
So we're spending far more and our primary
outcome for health, which is life or death,
we do the worst on.
So we have a terrible return on investment.
We're gonna take that fact, we're gonna just
put it aside.
We might come back to it, we might not.
Safety, I'm gonna introduce just a couple
quick facts and then we'll move on to the
other topics.
For safety, key things to keep in mind about
the United States is, we're a much more dangerous
country than the competitors, than these other
wealthy countries.
Our murder rate is more than twice and in
some cases, ten times more than the other
countries that I compared with.
These other wealthy countries are much safer
in the sense that you're far less likely to
be murdered.
And then the flip side of the whole idea of
risk, is then the question of incarceration.
And in incarceration we see a similar difference
in that we see the United States incarcerates
roughly three and sometimes ten times more
than other countries.
An incredible incarceration rate, one that
is almost at the same scale that the Soviet
Union had during the Gulag days.
So we have this very different world in the
United States with regard to our internal
safety.
Let's take those facts and put them aside
for now, and let's focus on the other three
topics that I think are really interesting;
democracy, education and equality.
First I'll talk a little about democracy because
of course we have the excitement of the upcoming
Presidential elections.
When we think about democracy, there's lots
of ways you can compare two different democracies.
One of the most common ways you do it is you
look at the question of competition and participation.
Competition refers to not just how competitive
are the elections, but also people's ability
to voice themselves in government.
And then of course the participation is very
simple, that's voter turnout.
When you combine those metrics, what you find
is that the United States does very poorly.
We have the lowest voter turnout of any of
the comparative countries.
Now that alone is a symptom of a democracy
in trouble.
Besides the voter turnout being so low, we
have another situation.
The situation is, our structure of elections
is very different from other wealthy countries.
Let me explain that a little bit, what we
have in many of our elections is called a
single seat, winner take all election.
Let's say you're voting for someone who's
in the House of Representatives, you have
your vote, whether you're a Democrat, Republican,
Libertarian, Green Party whichever party you're
from and you choose to vote for your candidate,
the candidate that gets the highest percent
of votes goes to Washington.
Meanwhile, everyone who voted for another
party, their vote basically got ignored.
What do you have in the rest of the world?
Well, 38 of the 41 largest democracies in
the world use proportional representation.
A very simple idea, let the distribution of
representatives, the parties that are represented,
reflect the voting distribution.
So if 40% of the people voted Democrat and
45 voted Republican and five voted Libertarian,
then the representatives would be that same
distribution.
Why is this a big deal?
It's a huge deal, it's a huge deal because
with this single seat winner take all method
that we use and almost no other country generally
uses, we have a few problems.
We have the problem of gerrymandering, we
create these very strange diagrams of what
a county looks like and then that seeks to
isolate.
It minimizes the voices of other parties,
and it allows you to lock in seats.
Gerrymandering leads to something else which
is extremism.
Politicians who know that they are in a Republican
district or in a Democrat district know they
can be as radical as they want and get reelected.
They don’t need to communicate to the entire
people who are in their district.
They only need to communicate to their party.
And so it drives the parties farther and farther
apart.
There are lots of other issues as well.
But from the point of view of competitive
intelligence, the key thing to recognize is
our method of electing officials is different
from what's done in most of the world.
Not only is it different, but it's not so
good.
So why do we have it?
Well, we developed our democracy more than
two hundred years ago.
We were at the cutting edge.
We were a leader in the world.
But we haven't evolved our systems.
The rest of the world has improved its technology
of voting.
Whereas we're using basically the same system
from over two hundred years ago.
The analogy in the Google world would be if
you were programming with punch cards.
Wish ya luck.
So moral of the story is, we have a system
that is antiquated and we're not updating
it using the latest technology for democracy.
And it's not such recent technology.
This has been around for many many many decades.
So we have that whole idea of proportional
representation.
On other comparisons that are done, for instance
the World Bank does a nice comparison of democracies,
what they've seen is other countries such
as Australia rank very well.
What does Australia do that's different from
the United States?
They have this great idea, it's called preferential
voting.
Instead of going into the voting booth and
me picking my candidate, and let's say I do
like the idea of third party, in the United
States if I pick that third party I'm basically
throwing my vote in the garbage pail unfortunately.
Because of that winner take all.
In Australia, you rank order your candidates.
This is my favorite, this is my second favorite,
this is my third favorite and you just go
down the list.
If no candidate gets a majority, the candidate
who got the least amount of votes, they reallocate
based on what the second choices was.
And they keep doing that until a candidate
has a majority.
Makes perfect sense, works very well in Australia,
works in some other countries as well.
The United States, we can adopt it.
It's a great example of using a better method
of voting.
So we have those two areas where we can improve.
Of course we have the other thing we have
to keep in mind, the United States is the
only country that has two steps.
Register, then vote.
Most wealthy countries, the government takes
an active roll in making sure that anyone
who files taxes or has a driver's license
or does any involvement with the government
officially, is already preregistered to vote.
So you don't have this two-step process.
Other countries are trying to enable their
voters.
Whereas we see there's a very active process
in the United States to keep people from being
able to vote.
We're creating higher and higher bars for
people to jump over to vote.
Whereas in other countries it's a much simpler
process for you to vote.
And that impacts our voter turnout.
Lastly on democracy, I'm just going to mention
two quick things, back to the idea of us using
an old system.
The first thing that I want to mention is
there is no other wealthy country where if
you live in the capital, you don't get a voting
representative in Congress.
This is only in the United States.
Washington DC residents, they have no voting
representative in Congress.
Is there any logical reason for it?
Absolutely not.
When they wrote the Constitution it wasn't
a perfect document.
And there are things that had to be improved.
In this particular case, what's preventing
DC from having a voting representative?
Partisan politics, nothing more.
Meanwhile the rest of the world looks at the
United States on that particular issue and
they laugh, because we are telling the rest
of the world that we are a shining example
of democracy yet citizens in our capital don't
even have a voting representative in their
legislation.
The last thing I was going to mention is the
Electoral College.
The Electoral College is a system that, well
let's just say has not been impersonated by
any other country in the world.
Many countries have identified our separation
of powers as being an excellent idea and they've
adopted it to their usage.
Many countries have admired the structure
of our Constitution, the way it was framed,
and they've modified it but they’ve used
that as a model.
No country has looked at our Electoral College
and said that's a great idea, I've gotta take
it.
And the reason why they don't do that is because
it's one of the most anti-democratic institutes
you could possibly imagine.
I'm just gonna mentioned two specific things
about it being highly undemocratic.
The first one is we're here in New York.
And if you're here in New York or California
or Texas, the number of representatives per
resident is much much lower than if you live
in a low population state, if you're in Wyoming
for instance.
So when the Electoral College and in voting
for the President what that says is, people
in Wyoming are much more important than people
who live in New York or California or Texas.
It's not one person one vote, it's not even
close.
It's off by often a factor of three.
Now that’s a huge disparity with no logical
justification.
All you need to do is use the popular vote,
it's not complicated.
Many countries do it, it's very straight forward.
And we do vote, so they could easily count
the popular vote.
I don't actually expect that the Electoral
College is going to get torn apart anytime
soon.
So we’ll talk about a realistic solution
to that.
But the other thing that's worth mentioning
is the Electoral College and its general process
of all or nothing voting is also what creates
this crazy system of swing states.
And think about a swing state for a second.
In the 2008 election, the Obama campaign spent
roughly 20,000 dollars with advertising in
Illinois.
And they spent about 40 million in Pennsylvania.
These states have roughly the same population;
they have exactly the same number of representatives.
But if you lived in Illinois, he wasn’t
going to waste any money bothering to advertise
or reach out to that state.
Why?
Because he knows he's going to quote unquote
win the state and then everyone in the state,
it'll appear as if they supported Obama, even
though a very large percentage didn’t.
Meanwhile, Pennsylvania, a swing state, those
citizens are much, much more important.
And so depending on where you happen to have
registered to say that you're living, you're
a much more important citizen or you basically
have no voice at all.
So, we have these two symptoms, very obvious
symptoms, of a problem in our democracy.
With the Electoral College we're not going
to see it disappear anytime soon, but Maine
and Nebraska have already done a simple solution.
They allocate their electors based on voting.
They use proportional representation, trivial
idea.
We don't have to have it all or none.
It's not required.
Every state could simply implement that rule
and you would not have disconnects between
the popular vote and the electoral vote.
Simple solution?
Using that best practice of proportional representation.
Let's take those ideas of democracy and put
them aside for now and let's focus on education.
Education is a really interesting topic because
it's another area where the data show very
clearly that the United States was the world
leader.
And we've declined a lot.
And when I say we used to be the world leader,
what I mean is we used to have the highest
rate of college education in the world.
Now we're out of the top 15.
We are an innovator in providing free primary
and secondary education to everyone.
Universal access to it, an innovator in that
and with our GI bill, we really lead the forefront
of encouraging people to go to college.
We've slipped behind and we can see that slipping
behind at all levels of education.
Our rate of pre-primary school is average
to below average compared to other wealthy
countries.
And there's a huge disparity in who goes to
pre-primary education.
Children from middle class families have a
20% higher likelihood of going to pre-primary
school than children from poorer families.
Twenty percent difference based on who your
parents are.
So we see we're behind at the youngest levels
and that there's a huge gap.
As people age they reach high school.
Our rate of secondary education graduation
went from 10% in the early 1900s to the seventy-ish
range.
And it did that around the 1970s.
And it's leveled off ever since, we have not
improved.
Compared other countries we have about an
average rate of secondary school graduation.
But what about the quality of the education?
There's these great cross-country exams, there's
PISA, there's PiMs.
And if you look at some of these cross-country
exams it tells us that the United States,
on areas of science and math, for instance,
tend to do slightly below average.
The top countries, countries like Korea, Japan,
and Canada, do extremely well, the United
States somewhere around here.
But then we get these disparities.
Children from wealthier neighborhoods do extremely
well on these exams; in fact they would out
perform any country.
Whereas children from poorer neighborhoods
do much worse than any of the wealthy countries.
This separation based on the wealth of your
family is a very important factor.
Now that would be true in any country but,
the relationship between how well you do on
these high school exams and the social-economic
class of your family is more important in
the United States than any other wealthy country.
They've looked at the relationship between
socio-economic class and performance on these
PISA scores, and what they see is that the
United States has a far higher dependence
than any other country taking the exam.
That's a problem we're gonna get back to when
we start talking about equality.
Going further up, we see tertiary education
we have an above average rate and we'd like
to continue to do that.
Now it's not all bad.
We do have a real wonderful competitive advantage
in the United States.
We have some of the highest quality colleges,
universities and graduate schools in the world.
It's a competitive advantage and we need to
keep that competitive advantage in the back
of our minds, because we need to leverage
competitive advantages and at the same time
correct for issues that are going on in other
parts of society.
Let's take that excellence for a second from
Korea and drill down into it.
The data's very consistent; Korea does outstanding
in education from the high school level to
the tertiary education level.
So what are the things that they are doing
in Korea that we could learn from?
Well let's start with the basics, number of
days of school in the United States?
We don’t have a national requirement, it's
state level but there's a huge variation and
we roughly spend about 180 days of school,
at primary and secondary level.
In South Korea, 220 days.
Roughly 40 days more of school.
In 40 more days of school, you could learn
a lot.
But additionally it's the structure of when
you take your time off.
They don't have that incredibly long summer
break, where we all remember, or we all recall
forgetting everything we had learned up to
May/June and then showed up back at September
and you had to catch up.
So the length of school year, that's just
an obvious example and there's a very strong
correlation, over 85%, between length of school
and the score of these cross-country exams.
So increasing the length of school, a very
obvious step but not a silver bullet.
What's more important is focusing on the strategy
that they've used in Korea, that's worked
very well.
They recruit the top students to become primary
school teachers.
Only the top students are eligible to do that
very important role in society.
And then they get paid very well.
Primary school teachers in South Korea get
paid roughly twice the GDP per capita.
In the United States, roughly GDP per capita.
So in South Korea, it's a well-paid position,
very selective who can get into it.
They also add a lot of ongoing job training
to improve the skill set.
So they invest in their teachers, and they
have very low turnover rates, roughly 1% per
year.
The United States?
Unfortunately these days, roughly half the
people who go into education graduated from
the bottom third of their class.
We don't pay teachers well.
Roughly GDP per capita.
If you go back, about 40 years ago, we used
to give it a much higher rate.
About 40 years ago in the United States we
paid roughly 175% of GDP per capita.
Teachers used to be well paid and it used
to draw some of the top talent in the United
States.
So here we're not drawing the top talent,
we're not paying them well, it doesn't get
the prestige that it does in many other countries.
And our turnover rates, consequently, are
much higher.
The other thing to keep in mind is how we
fund our education.
About 90% of the money for public education
in the United States comes from local sources.
That is, your local government, your state
government.
The federal government has very little influence
on it.
What does that mean?
Well, it has a big, big difference because
if you grew up in a poorer neighborhood and
the money that's being raised for your school
is coming from your neighborhood, you have
far less money per student than if you grew
up in a wealthier neighborhood in the United
States.
That disparity has huge implications.
The quality of the learning facilities are
worse, you have less availability of quality
textbooks, computers and the salaries that
you pay teachers tends to be much lower.
So the wealthier neighborhoods they have far
more money to spend on education, better learning
facilities, everything is quite strong there.
And they draw the best teachers, the most
experienced teachers 'cause they pay more.
And the students who have to go to the poorer
schools, worse learning facilities, worse
opportunities for learning and they end up
with usually the least experienced teachers.
A terrible cycle for students who already
started out with a lower rate of pre-primary
education and then their learning opportunities
are worse.
No Child Left Behind originally had two components
to it.
One was this aggressive testing of students
to see how much they're learning.
The other one was an aggressive monitoring
of the students opportunity for learning.
The quality of the facilities of the education
that's available to them.
They dropped one of them and that was a mistake.
They need to monitor both.
Now, that last example I gave it's another
example where the United States is very different.
Other countries there's a much stronger role
for the federal government in education, very
much about equilibrating the opportunities.
And we see that there are certain advantages
to that.
We have a separation of federal and state
powers and we're not going to get away from
that.
And I'm not advising that.
But all I am advising is, we should learn
from what goes in other countries in terms
of giving equality of opportunity.
Children from the poorest neighborhoods should
not have the worst opportunities for learning.
They shouldn’t suffer because of the fact
that they grew up in a poorer neighborhood.
We're gonna take all that information about
education and we're gonna put it aside for
a second because it brings up the whole idea
of equality.
We've seen it come up a few time already,
but it's gonna come up explicitly right now.
And when I say equality, there's so many ways
of measuring it.
We have income inequality, we all know what
income is.
We have pretax, post-tax income.
And that's an outcome measure, when we talk
about income inequality, one of the things
that we'll see is that the United States has
a far higher rate of income inequality than
other wealthy countries.
Well, income over time, over years and over
generations leads to wealth.
And it's not surprising that knowing that
we have higher rates of both pretax and post
adjustment income inequality that our wealth
inequality is also much higher than other
wealthy countries.
So we have those two.
We have the equality of opportunity, I'm gonna
spend a bit more time on that later.
And then lastly we have other factors like
gender equality.
The opportunities for women, and there you
can measure it in many ways.
In terms of economic opportunities we're about
average.
In terms of the political representation of
women in legislature, we're very far below
average.
We don’t have the same level of representation.
The UK had Margaret Thatcher, we've not had
a female President.
Things like that, but we're gonna focus more
of the conversation on the equality of opportunity
and income inequality.
To really drive home a point of disparity
between the United States and other countries
and decisions that we're making as a culture.
If we go back to the idea of income inequality
for a second, what we've seen is that the
inequality has increased over the past few
decades.
The pretax and the post-tax.
The pretax has increased for a number of reasons;
a lot of them are related to how we structure
our corporations.
How we pay executives, how we pay people in
finance.
Our CEO to worker ratio is much much higher
than other countries.
And it has exploded over the past few decades.
That explosion has corresponded at the same
time to a vast weakening in the strength of
unions and a weakening in the voice of shareholders.
The owners of companies, shareholders, have
virtually no say on how much an executive
gets paid.
That's a very strange proposition of a business.
And in many countries that's not true.
Germany for instance, there's a much stronger
voice that employees have in the compensation
of everyone, including the executives.
So you have a different structure and you
have less extremes of income.
Now, you also have another factor that's playing
in.
A lot of people talk about the drive of globalization,
forcing higher rates of income inequality.
And it's certainly a fact that income from
people who are doing manual labor, well that
could potentially now compete with people
from other countries.
And it could suppress those wages.
But at the same time, you have not seen an
explosion in salary for people who have a
college degree.
In fact, it's been completely stagnant for
30 years.
Moreover, there are 4 of the thirteen comparative
countries saw an income equality increase,
not income inequality.
It went to opposite direction.
So for those people who say, well, this is
just a function of globalization and the United
States as a society has no role to play in
the increasing inequality are just denying
reality.
If that were true, then every country would
have seen it go up.
Rather, we have these changes in standards
and norms and our tax structure.
We have moved our tax structure to a point
where wealthy people often pay very little
in taxes.
It's not just the anecdotes that Warren Buffet
gives about him paying a lower rate than his
secretary, we all have the highly publicized
example of Mitt Romney making millions in
the last few years and paying a tax rate that
is certainly half or less than many people
in this room.
So that's all in the income inequality, both
before and after adjustments.
But I really am interested in the equality
of opportunity.
The equality of opportunity is something that
I take very personally because I grew up here
in the United States, of course.
And we grew up with the American dream.
The idea that no matter who you are, where
you came from, if you were talented, if you
worked hard you could become anything you
wanted to be.
And that's still true, you can.
But, the chances of you moving up, socioeconomically
in the United States turn out to be far less
than other wealthy countries.
Now that’s a tremendous disconnect.
It's a disconnect because intuitively Americans
grow up with the idea that we have more social
mobility.
We think of European countries as having very
class societies.
We think we're very mobile socially.
It's not true.
Here's some data to give you a feel for it.
If you look at quintiles, that is dividing
people up in to percentiles based on the wealth
of their family, the bottom 20% all the way
up to the top 20%, people who grew up in the
United States in the lowest twenty percentile
of wealth, the chances of them moving out
of that lowest percentile, isn't very good.
Forty-two percent, roughly, stay in that lowest
quintile, 58% roughly, leave.
Well we expect that a certain percentage will
stay in the lowest quintile, just by definition.
But that’s not a very good movement out
of that poorest range.
What about in other countries?
In other countries, roughly, high 20s to maybe
30% stay in the lowest and 70% or more leave.
You're more stuck in the lowest quintile in
the United States than in other wealthy countries.
And what about the true rags to riches story,
the Horatio Alger of going from the poorest
quintile to the wealthiest?
The rate in the United States is lower than
in any other wealthy country that's been measured.
We have less of chance of going from that
very poor beginning and becoming wealthy than
if you grew up in other wealthy countries.
Less social mobility, this completely contradicts
American intuition.
They do these world value surveys, and in
these world value surveys Americans are far
more likely to say that their country is a
meritocracy than people in other wealthy countries.
We have more confidence in that.
Americans are far more likely to believe that
people who are poor are poor because they
either did not try hard enough or lack of
talent.
We blame people for not succeeding more than
other countries.
With that said, our perspective completely
is a disconnect from the reality of the data.
Believing that we have more social mobility
when in fact we have far less.
It's intimately related to our educational
system.
The disparities in education, the person who
grew up in that poor neighborhood who had
a far less chance of going to pre-primary
school, which has been shown to be a strong
predictor of factors not just like long term
education but also affecting crime, all the
way up the quality of your high school education.
And the huge disparity, more dependent on
where you came from in terms of your score
on that high school exam than in other countries,
all the way up to the chances of you going
to college at every road along the way.
And college is a huge factor in moving from
poor to a wealthier area.
Of the people who started in the poorest quintile,
if you got a college degree, only 16% stayed
there,1-6, that is vast, vast majority get
out.
If you don’t get that college degree, nearly
50% will be right back in that same quintile.
Intergenerational poverty.
So education really is a critical factor.
And fixing the issues with education, public
education, from the lowest levels all the
way up is the best way to start addressing
it.
But it's not just education, I want to leave
you with a key thought in this area of equality
which is, there are still racial inequalities,
there are still gender inequalities that will
exist even if we correct for many of the issues
regarding education.
And the area with racial inequality, here's
a powerful fact.
An African American and a Caucasian American
who both have finished high school, the Caucasian
American earns roughly 25% more.
African American and a Caucasian American
both have finished a college degree, Caucasian
American earns roughly 25% more.
African American, Caucasian American both
have finished Masters degrees, Caucasian American
earns roughly 25% more.
So education will certainly help, but we still
have some pretty clear disparities that we
need to address as well.
Now I've taken you with a little bit of a
drop into health and a little drop into safety,
we've talked a lot about democracy, talked
a lot about education, talked a lot about
equality.
We've seen that the United States has areas
where it needs to improve, areas where it
used to be the best and it slipped off.
Education, we used to be one of the best educated
work forces in the world.
And we're declining.
In health, we used to have one of the top
10 life expectancies in the world, we're far
out of the top 10 now.
For health, we've comparatively declined.
Safety, we've always been a dangerous country,
much more so than other countries.
And we continue to be so to this day.
But our incarceration rate has exploded, it's
three to four times more than it was in the
'70s and that explosion has been based on
many of the laws that have been passed.
In other areas, in democracy, we were a leader,
we were an innovator with our Constitution,
with our Declaration of Independence, we created
modern representative democracies that led
the world.
But we haven't learned lessons that the other
world has learned over the last couple hundred
years.
Better ways to vote, correcting errors in
our Constitution.
There are errors, we need to correct them.
Lastly, in equality, we have this painful
disconnect between our belief that we're a
wonderful meritocracy and the data which shows
very clearly that we're actually more stuck
in where you came from than in any other country.
Case in point for that last one is the fact
that in the United States, children from poor
families who are top performing students have
roughly the exact same chance of going to
college than the children who are the worst
students from wealthy families.
Wealth, unfortunately is trumping talent right
now in the United States.
We need to correct that.
It's not all bad, we have competitive advantages,
we have areas that we can use as ways to improve.
We have some of the best colleges, universities
and graduate schools in the world.
And they draw top talent, they bring them
here.
What do we need to do?
We need to come out with better ways to help
them stay.
Help them build the future of America.
I know Google knows very well this story so
I don’t have to retell it regarding your
founders, but that's the point about bringing
top talent in and enabling them to stay.
Besides our educational system at the tertiary
level which draws top talent, we have other
advantages.
We have some of the best research in the world,
not just in medical research but in technology
research as well.
Companies like Google leading the world and
drawing that top talent in.
And we need to bring them in.
We also have one of the most friendly business
environments in the world.
This is a great country to create a new company,
and we need to bring those innovators in,
those entrepreneurs, draw them and give them
an environment where they can stay.
Let's take those competitive advantages and
use them.
We have a tremendous amount of racial and
cultural diversity.
That's an advantage; it gives us opportunities
that many countries don’t have.
Let's use those.
So we have areas that we're lagging behind,
areas that we have fallen, where we used to
be the best.
And we have these wonderful competitive advantages,
we need to use them.
Well, sounds great, I've heard the data, I've
heard about these best practices, roll forward.
We have some barriers to implementation, just
gonna mention a few of them, the barriers
to implementation include lack of awareness.
If you talked to most Americans, they will
not believe that we're not the best in health.
Yet when they were having all the discussions
about the Patient Protection and Affordable
Care Act, the phrase that kept being used
was, 'we have the best health care system
out there'.
It's just not true, now we do have something
that’s the best, we have the best leading
edge health technology in the world.
We do have something that's great.
But our public health is not so good.
And you need to make sure people realize that,
educate them on where we're actually doing.
Show them the data.
You know, the book that I wrote, "Measure
of a Nation", it uses data that's easily publicly
available.
The links are there; you can connect right
to all the data and compare the United States.
You'll see in many areas we're not doing so
well.
So the first part is awareness and showing
the data.
The second barrier is complacency.
Complacency takes many roles in the United
States.
We have the reality of we're, we're a wealthy
country.
We don’t generally have people starving
in the streets.
While our social supports are much lower than
other wealthy countries, and that's related
to our belief, mistaken belief, in being a
meritocracy.
We have enough that people are not fighting
for survival and as result, you don’t see
the passion in the streets, the changes in
the United States.
The declining performance in our health system,
the declining performance in our education,
the declining effectiveness of our democracy
has been gradual.
And it's almost like the story of the frog
in the water.
It's a parable, I don’t believe it's actually
true, but it's the idea of putting the frog
in the water and turning on the heat.
And the frog will only notice when it's too
late, that the water's boiling because the
change is gradual.
Now, that particular example rings a little
bit true for the United States because we
have not seen a switch being flipped.
We didn't go from having one of the longest
life expectancies in the world and then in
a year dropping.
It was gradual.
We didn't go from having the highest rate
of tertiary education in the world to dropping
out of the top 10.
It was gradual.
And our democracy did not lose its power to
represent over a scale of one or two years.
It's been gradual.
So, there's the complacency.
The other factors are democracy itself and
that’s why I spent some time talking about
how we are very different in how we implement
our democracy.
Our democratic system prevents a lot of change.
And we've also seen in a lot of studies that
those who are coming from the poorest neighborhoods
have almost no influence on legislation.
A lot of it's due to how we elect officials
as well as the influence of money in politics
in the United States.
That didn’t just start with Citizens United
but it certainly accelerated with Citizens
United.
So we have all of those influences, things
that are holding us back.
Our political system, complacency, lack of
awareness and the last factor I want to mention
is just the reality of our system has worked
very well for some groups.
Not just some companies who've done very well
because of our health system, the for-profit
world that isn't seen in other wealthy countries.
It's not just our educational system where
many areas are benefiting while others are
suffering.
It's not just in safety where we have for-profit
prisons, not a norm, an exception for the
rest of the world.
But also in our political system.
Our two party system works well if you're
in the two parties.
And if you fundamentally believe in those
two parties, but if you have a different opinion,
then you're not able to express it.
The groups that have benefited from our current
system, they will defend their benefits.
So for those who want to make change, you
want to take that competitive intelligence,
that data, you wanna leverage that to see
can we apply some of things that are working
well in other parts of the world?
Remember, you're gonna have to fight the fact
that there's a low awareness of data.
There's complacency.
There's the issues in our democracy itself
and lastly you're gonna have to push against
those who are benefiting greatly from our
current system.
With all that said, it's a fight worth having.
It's a fight worth having because we have
wonderful advantages here, we have great opportunities
to leverage those advantages and improve on
the areas that are not doing as well.
Why should we?
Very simple, because our country has been
great.
It deserves to continue to be great, not just
for the next year or two.
But for the 50 years, 100 years down the road.
We need to learn how to improve.
Imagine if Google decided tomorrow that they
would just stop studying the competitive landscape,
they would just ignore everything that's going
out there.
Any new developments in algorithms, let's
pay no attention to it.
Any new types of search, any new innovations
that are going on in advertising or any of
those, if you decide to just ignore it, well
you wouldn't be around in too many years.
For the United States, we can't afford to
ignore the lessons that the rest of the world
has learned.
Rather, we need to learn them so that we can
continue to be great over a time scale of
50, 100 years.
Thank you very much.
[applause]
>>female presenter: The microphones are open
for questions, if anyone has questions.
And the book is available for sale up here
for $5.
[pause]
>>female Presenter: No questions?
>>Howard Friedman: [laughs]
[pause]
>>Male#1: I'm afraid this is more in the way
of a comment than a question.
Very little if anything of what you said was
new or news or a surprise.
Very little of it was unknown, I suspect to
most people in this audience.
There was one theme though, that I sort of
took out as a sort of undertone to your general
presentation, that we don't know what's going
on in the rest of the world.
We don't know that everyone else has better
health care, that we don't, and therefore
that we don't have it.
That we don't know that everyone else has
better democracy and therefore we don’t
have it.
And while it may be true that many people
do not know these things, that’s not an
accident and I'm not convinced it's particularly
relevant.
The problem as you began to allude to toward
the end of your talk, is not that we are ignorant
about better systems or ignorant about the
problems that exist health care, in safety,
in democracy, in education and other areas.
The problem is that this really does, the
existing system in the United States, really
does serve the interests of a small group
of people very well.
Generally the people in power and the people
with more money and continues do so and that
the system as it exists and as it continues
to change toward the direction of greater
inequality and so forth, serves the interests
of the people in power better.
It's not an accident, it's not because we
don’t know.
It's a deliberate process and a deliberate
effort to change things in these directions
that you don’t like and I don’t like and
probably a lot of other people sitting in
the audience today don’t like.
And in particular when you talk about we or
the United States, as a group, you sort of
blur the differences here that are really
at the heart of the issue.
Because the United States does not have a
problem, some people in the United States
have a problem, maybe 80% of the people in
the United States have a big problem.
And the question is not does the United States
have a problem, is it better or not.
The question is why, how does the 80% organize
better to take more control and take more
power and take their appropriate share of
the resources from the 1%?
You can't talk about we, you can't talk about
the United States as if it's one thing, because
then you completely miss the real problem
and issue here.
>>Howard Friedman: So, thank you for the comment.
I very much appreciate it.
I'm gonna counter point, since it wasn’t
a question.
My counter points will be first, you're saying
that yes, everyone here in the Google audience
is well aware of that information and it's
not just cause you have your laptops in front
and you're checking the facts as I speak.
It's, you are at one of the most selective
companies in the world, for recruiting.
But I'm talking about a nation of 310+ million
people and the large percentage of Americans
are not aware of these facts.
And awareness is a major issue because ultimately
we do have voters and voters who are greater
aware are less likely, not perfectly unlikely,
to vote against their interests.
So-
>>male #1: -but awareness itself is not an
accident.
>>Howard Friedman: So I'm going to continue
with my counter point.
So there's 4 points that I raised and I agree
with you that awareness is 1 factor.
And I listed 4 key barriers.
The other one was complacency.
The other one was our political process, and
I think the there's a lot of agreement with
that, but we have to change a lot of the political
process itself.
The process of electing has to be changed.
And then lastly, and that's the point I think
that you were emphasizing in agreement with
me on was that those who are benefiting are
going to continue to defend their benefits
and they'll continue to take more.
And I want to take your point a little bit
further, because I finished the speech talking
about how to leverage our advantages and to
recognize our disadvantages.
I wanted to finish on kind of a positive on
purpose.
I would like to tell you my book does that,
it doesn't quite.
The book takes actually your exact point and
it says what if we don’t and if we don’t
make changes right now, the trajectory is
very clear as well.
I wanna see these changes happen.
I wanna see a United States that is robust,
not just for the 1 or 2 or 3% but for the
entire country.
On the other hand, if we don't, the trajectory
is very clear.
I've spent a lot of time traveling around
the world, we will end up in a world that
looks very much like Latin America or an oil
economy.
Where a few percent of the population live
in gated communities.
They have concierge physicians, they send
their children to private school.
They do not interact with the rest of the
country.
And the rest of the country is doing their
best just to make ends meet.
That's the long-term trajectory if we don't
correct, if we don’t make changes.
I prefer to inspire people on the positive
than on the negative.
As for the idea of using we, as in America,
it's a choice.
I'm making a conscious choice to focus people,
in this case it's focusing Americans on the
idea of a goal of greatness rather than aiming
at particular groups who are certainly trying
to steer a system to their own advantages
and away from others.
So I'm making a conscious choice, but I don’t
disagree with your factual statement.
How about that?
Other questions?
>>Male #2: Dr. Friedman, you spent a lot of
time talking about the different comparative
benchmarks and ways to compare the United
States to other industrialized nations, for
lack of a better term for myself.
Taking that a step further, if there are other
countries, not to be specific but if there
are other comparators that have figured out
that the water was starting to boil and have
made changes to their Constitutions, what
can we learn from that process?
Is it an Occupy Wall Street?
Is it, not to divide the United States into
different groups but how do you go to the
next meta-level.
What's the sequel, what's the 2.0 of your
book in terms of, OK, if there are things
to learn, and we agree to that, how do we
now make those changes?
And I care less whether it's Constitutional
Amendments or any of that stuff, but from
a process standpoint, how do we now learn
and actually do that based on what you've
seen other nations.
Because I have to believe the British Empire
figured a few things they needed to throw
away, as did the Romans etcetera, what does
our Empire need to do based on your comparative
analysis?
>>Howard Friedman: OK, so I think we're focusing
this question more on the inequality, it's
tied to the first comment.
So I'll stay away from the health and safety
and focus it on that particular point.
Well, you can look at other countries, you
can look at Brazil which is a middle income
country.
They made a conscious effort, they zeroed
in on this question, and they have made huge
differences.
But we can stay inside the United States.
We saw this rise before, we had this.
We had this at the late 1800s, early 1900s.
This is where the robber baron era days came
from, and we had massive inequality that took
off.
And then we had a counter movement.
First, there was Teddy Roosevelt with the
trust busting.
He didn’t just go after the companies, he
also aggressively went after income inequality.
It came back later, it came back in the Progressive
Movement.
And in the Progressive Movement, what did
they do?
They instituted increases in the rates of
taxation so that it became a much more progressive
tax system, they also made other legislative
changes.
How did those go about?
They were popular movements.
The people have to care.
For any of the change we're talking about.
Whether we're talking about the health, the
safety or in this case, focusing on the issue
of equality in opportunity.
The people have to get out, they have to voice
their opinion, they have to make themselves
heard.
If they stay in their homes and they're complacent,
nothing will change.
Now, our democracy, unfortunately right now
does not listen well to the voice of the people.
But it does listen enough when millions are
out there in the streets.
And that seems to be way America can move
forward.
Because the legislative changes to change
how we vote, those take a long time.
But people in the streets?
There is responses to.
Take the Tea Party on one hand, they had passion,
they created changes.
Whether we agree or disagree with the direction
the changes, they did make changes.
Occupy Wall Street, I'm surprised that they
didn't get more momentum and maybe they will
come back in full swing in the fall.
But you need that passion, you need it at
the top of people's agenda in order to implement
a difference.
Simply having conversations starts the process.
But pushing it further to people actively
protesting, that's how democracy changes.
>>Female Presenter: That's all we have time
for, thank you.
>>Howard Friedman: Thank you very much.
[applause]